This episode is brought to you by Activia. You might already be eating yogurt, but not all yogurts are created equal. Activia contains over one billion probiotics per serving to survive and reach the gut alive. When it comes to gut health, Activia is the number one family doctor-recommended probiotic yogurt brand. Choose Activia, feel good from the inside out. Visitactivia.ca for more details. Midlife has a branding problem. Our middle years are often portrayed as a time of mounting stress, fading abilities, and looming regrets.
本期节目由 Activia 赞助播出。您可能已经在食用酸奶，但并非所有酸奶都生而平等。每份 Activia 含有超过十亿个益生菌，能够存活并抵达肠道。谈到肠道健康，Activia 是家庭医生推荐的首选益生菌酸奶品牌。选择 Activia，由内而外感受舒适。访问 activia.ca 了解更多详情。中年危机是一个品牌问题。我们的中年时期常被描绘成压力倍增、能力衰退和遗憾隐现的时期。
And can you even hear the word midlife without immediately thinking midlife crisis? But in recent decades, psychologists who study midlife have found that this gloomy picture is mostly unwarranted. For many people, the middle years, though stressful, are also rewarding. It's a time when we take on meaningful roles in our families and communities, become more comfortable with who we are, and make choices that will shape our health and well-being for decades to come. So why does the myth of the midlife crisis persist? What does science tell us about how we actually grow and change during these years? Will millennials who are now just entering midlife experience it in the same way their parents did?
甚至可以说，人们一听到“中年”这个词，就会立刻联想到“中年危机”。但近几十年来，研究中年的心理学家发现，这种阴郁的图景大多是没有根据的。对许多人来说，中年虽然充满压力，但也充满回报。这是一个我们在家庭和社区中承担重要角色、对自己是谁感到更加自在，并做出将塑造未来几十年健康与福祉的选择的时期。那么，为什么中年危机的神话依然存在？科学告诉我们，在这些年里我们实际上是如何成长和改变的？现在刚刚步入中年的千禧一代，会像他们的父母那样经历中年吗？
And what are the most important things you can do in midlife to set yourself up for more healthy decades? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association. Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Margie Lachman, the Minnie and Harold Fireman Professor of Psychology and the Director of the Lifespan Development Lab at Brandeis University. She has spent decades studying how adults grow and change over the lifespan, with a focus on midlife and later life.
在中年时期，为了让自己拥有更健康的几十年，你能做的最重要的事情是什么？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客。该协会旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。今天的嘉宾是玛吉·拉赫曼博士，她是布兰迪斯大学明妮与哈罗德·费尔曼心理学教授，也是生命周期发展实验室的主任。她花了数十年时间研究成年人如何在生命周期中成长和改变，重点关注中年和晚年。
The goal of her lab is to identify factors that affect how people age and develop interventions to protect health, well-being, and cognition in later life. Dr. Lachman is an APA fellow and has published hundreds of papers and peer-reviewed journals. Her research has been covered by news organizations including CBS, NBC, The New York Times, and NPR. Her new book called Primetime, A New Vision for Midlife, comes out in June. Dr. Lachman, thank you for joining me today. Thank you very much for having me. Let's start by a definition.
她实验室的目标是确定影响人们衰老方式的因素，并制定干预措施，以保护晚年的健康、福祉和认知能力。拉赫曼博士是美国心理学会会士，发表了数百篇论文和同行评审期刊文章。她的研究已被哥伦比亚广播公司、美国全国广播公司、《纽约时报》和美国国家公共电台等新闻机构报道。她的新书《黄金时间：中年新愿景》将于六月出版。拉赫曼博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。让我们从定义开始。
and how do you and other researchers define midlife? Are there set ages where it begins and ends? Yeah. Well, for the most part, we're talking about the 40s and 50s. And there are, of course, some people who think of themselves as middle-aged in their mid-30s, and some people in their 60s think of themselves as middle-aged. But what might surprise you is that it's really not about the number of candles on your birthday cake. it's really something related to the central roles that people play in midlife.
您和其他研究人员是如何定义中年的？它有明确的开始和结束年龄吗？是的。在大多数情况下，我们指的是 40 多岁和 50 多岁。当然，有些人 30 多岁就认为自己步入中年了，而有些人 60 多岁还认为自己是中年人。但可能会让你感到惊讶的是，这其实与你生日蛋糕上的蜡烛数量无关，它实际上与人们在中年时期扮演的核心角色有关。
So it's the sandwich generation. When you're caring for your kids or also helping your aging parents, you're literally in the middle and pulled in both directions. So that's what I think of as the essence of midlife. It's less about the chronological age and more about your unique and challenging position. Now, as I said in the intro, you pretty much can't say the word midlife without mentally hearing the word crisis following it. How much truth is there to the stereotype of a midlife crisis? Do they really exist? And if they do, what do they look like? Yes. So it does exist, but not for everybody. I think many people think it's inevitable,
所以这就是“三明治一代”。当你照顾孩子，同时还要帮助年迈的父母时，你实际上处于中间，被两头拉扯。这就是我认为的中年本质。它与其说是生理年龄，不如说是你独特且充满挑战的处境。正如我在开场白中所说，你几乎无法说出“中年”这个词而不联想到随之而来的“危机”。中年危机的刻板印象有多少真实性？它们真的存在吗？如果存在，它们是什么样子的？是的，它确实存在，但并非对每个人都如此。我认为许多人认为这是不可避免的，
like puberty or metapause, a rite of passage that we go through. But really, what's normal is at midlife to look back and look ahead. And that may raise some concerns and issues that people call a crisis, but it's really just about recalibrating and thinking about changes that you might want to make. In our study called Midas, Midlife in the United States, we did ask people if they had had a midlife crisis, and we found about 25% did say they had a midlife crisis. Yet when we looked further, what we found is that
就像青春期或更年期一样，是我们必须经历的成人礼。但实际上，中年时期的常态是回顾过去并展望未来。这可能会引发一些人们称之为危机的问题和担忧，但它实际上只是关于重新校准和思考你可能想要做出的改变。在我们名为 MIDUS（美国中年研究）的研究中，我们确实询问了人们是否经历过中年危机，我们发现大约 25% 的人表示他们经历过。然而，当我们进一步观察时，我们发现
the kinds of things they were talking about didn't necessarily occur in their middle years. They might have happened before they were 40 or well after the age of 50. And many of the events that they talked about were things like divorce or job loss or illness that could really happen at any age. What I would say is the hallmark of a midlife crisis is when people are concerned that time is running out or fears of getting older. And it was really a relatively small number of people who,
他们所谈论的事情并不一定发生在他们的中年时期。它们可能发生在他们 40 岁之前或 50 岁之后很久。他们谈论的许多事件，如离婚、失业或疾病，实际上可能发生在任何年龄。我想说的是，中年危机的标志是人们担心时间不多了，或者害怕变老。而真正经历这种危机感的人数相对较少。
experience that aspect of a crisis. Are there other myths about midlife that you'd like to dispel? Yeah, one that I talk about in my book is the myth of stability. And this is really this assumption that once you get to age 40 or 50, you're kind of stuck with who you are and you can't really make any changes. And some of this was really born out of what psychologists believe for a long period of time. It really is only relatively recently that even psychologists believe that personality can change. There was this notion for many years that personality was set in stone or set like
还有其他关于中年的神话需要消除吗？是的，我在书中谈到了一个“稳定性神话”。这实际上是一种假设，即一旦你到了 40 或 50 岁，你就被自己的现状所困，无法做出任何改变。其中一些观点确实源于心理学家长期以来的信念。直到最近，心理学家才开始相信人格是可以改变的。多年来，人们一直认为人格是固定不变的，就像
plaster and that we really couldn't make changes. But indeed, there's been research more recently that shows that people can change naturally just by aging. People become typically less neurotic. Maybe they also become more conscientious. There's been evidence. to show that. And the other thing is that you can change in many different ways. Many people want to become less neurotic, which is associated with anxiety and depression. And you can get help from a professional as one mechanism for making changes, but you can also make changes on your own by changing behaviors. And there are even apps there that are available for people to change personality. So if you wanted to become less introverted, for example.
石膏一样，我们无法做出改变。但事实上，最近的研究表明，人们可以通过衰老自然地发生改变。人们通常会变得不那么神经质。也许他们也会变得更有责任心。已有证据表明了这一点。另一件事是，你可以通过多种方式改变。许多人希望变得不那么神经质，这与焦虑和抑郁有关。你可以从专业人士那里获得帮助作为改变的一种机制，但你也可以通过改变行为来自己做出改变。甚至还有可供人们改变人格的应用程序。例如，如果你想变得不那么内向。
I meet many people in my classes or at the university who are very quiet. They make a conscious effort to change. And that means just speaking up more in meetings or attending more social functions, engaging in conversations. So this myth of stability really is something that we want to address. So you can teach a midlife dog new tricks. Exactly. You know, many people fear that in midlife, that that's when they're going to start to lose their cognitive edge.
我在课堂上或大学里遇到过许多非常安静的人。他们有意识地努力去改变。这意味着在会议中更积极地发言，或参加更多的社交活动，参与对话。所以，这个稳定性神话确实是我们想要解决的问题。所以，中年人也可以学到新东西。正是如此。你知道，许多人担心在中年时期，他们会开始失去认知优势。
But in the book, you talk about how it's actually a balance point, that it's a time when some types of intelligence begin to decline, but others grow. How should people think about intelligence, memory, and creativity in midlife? Yes. So there's two aspects of intelligence that we typically think about, the fluid intelligence, which involves abstract reasoning, analytic thinking. That's on a downward path, starting somewhere in early midlife, but the changes are very gradual, and they don't really affect what we can do in everyday life. On the other hand, crystallized intelligence, which reflects the knowledge and experience that we accumulate as we grow, that's continuing to increase, and it doesn't even reach its high point until much later in life.
但在书中，你谈到了它实际上是一个平衡点，在这个时期，某些类型的智力开始下降，而另一些则在增长。人们应该如何看待中年的智力、记忆力和创造力？是的。我们通常考虑两种智力：流体智力，涉及抽象推理和分析思维。它从中年早期开始走下坡路，但变化非常缓慢，并不会真正影响我们在日常生活中的能力。另一方面，晶体智力反映了我们随着成长积累的知识和经验，它在持续增长，甚至直到晚年才达到顶峰。
So we hypothesized that this would be the best of both worlds, because in midlife, These two kinds of intelligence in a sense intersect. The fluid intelligence isn't at its low point. The crystallized intelligence is not at its high point. So you're functioning quite well. And I did a study with two economists to test this out, not in the lab, as we usually do, but actually in real life using patent records. So we looked at inventors and their ages.
因此，我们假设这将是两全其美的，因为在中年时期，这两种智力在某种意义上是交叉的。流体智力没有处于最低点，晶体智力也没有处于最高点。所以你运作得相当好。我和两位经济学家做了一项研究来测试这一点，不是像我们通常那样在实验室里，而是通过专利记录在现实生活中进行。所以我们观察了发明家和他们的年龄。
And what we found is what we expected that there was a peak in inventions in early midlife. And we thought that made perfect sense, because although some things like maybe your memory isn't quite as sharp as it was earlier, or you might be slower at processing, new information, your experience and your accumulated knowledge, your wisdom, those skills really come into play when engaged in work such as invention. A few moments ago you mentioned the long-term study you've been involved in Midas or Midlife in the U.S., and you've been working on that for a very long time. Tell us about the study what it looks at, why it's so significant and it's still going on, right? Yes. So Midas, our Midlife in the United States, is really a groundbreaking study. We started 30 years ago when we really knew very little about midlife.
我们发现的结果正如我们所预期的，发明在中年早期达到顶峰。我们认为这非常有道理，因为虽然有些事情，比如你的记忆力可能不如以前敏锐，或者处理新信息的速度可能较慢，但你的经验和积累的知识、你的智慧，这些技能在从事发明等工作时确实发挥了作用。刚才你提到了你参与的长期研究 MIDUS（美国中年研究），你已经为此工作了很长时间。告诉我们这项研究，它关注什么，为什么它如此重要，而且它还在进行中，对吧？是的。所以 MIDUS，我们的美国中年研究，确实是一项开创性的研究。我们 30 年前开始这项研究时，对中年知之甚少。
We knew a lot more about early life. and later life, but there was a big gap in the middle. We knew nothing, really, except from clinicians who told us about how many people were having midlife crisis. And so we were very interested to understand why some people age so well, while others struggle and don't do as well, both physically and psychologically and cognitively. So we used this study really to follow the same people over time with a lifespan approach. And we started with a large sample, and we've now studied them for over 30 years. We've added additional people to the sample. And so as we follow these people over time, we're able to see what are the factors that lead to better
我们对早年和晚年了解得更多，但中间存在巨大的空白。我们一无所知，除了临床医生告诉我们有多少人正在经历中年危机。因此，我们非常有兴趣了解为什么有些人衰老得如此好，而另一些人却在挣扎，在身体、心理和认知方面表现不佳。所以我们利用这项研究，通过生命周期的方法长期跟踪同一群人。我们从一个大样本开始，现在已经研究了他们 30 多年。我们还在样本中增加了额外的人员。因此，随着我们长期跟踪这些人，我们能够看到哪些因素会导致更好的
outcomes in a variety of different areas. And the payoff, really, for this kind of long-term longitudinal work, is that if you identify problems early on, you can intervene before they become a crisis. So we find that the investments that you make in early adulthood and midlife really have long-term effects on later life. So the sleep that you prioritize or the friendships, the activity that you do, they really do what I call compound interest for your later years. You started looking at the idea of midlife in grad school and there really wasn't a lot of research. What was the traditional thinking about midlife back then that made it so uninteresting to researchers? Yeah, that's a great question.
在不同领域的结果。这种长期纵向研究的真正回报是，如果你及早发现问题，你可以在它们演变成危机之前进行干预。我们发现，你在成年早期和中年所做的投资确实对晚年有长期影响。所以你优先考虑的睡眠、友谊，以及你所做的活动，它们确实产生了我所说的晚年“复利”。你在研究生院开始研究中年这个概念时，当时并没有太多的研究。当时关于中年的传统观点是什么，使得它对研究人员来说如此乏味？是的，这是一个很好的问题。
So when I started in grad school, this lifespan approach was relatively new. In fact, what we really were taught was that growth and development pretty much came to a hall in adolescence. And a lot of that stems from early theorists like Freud or Piaget who really thought that your cognitive or psychological development was done by the time you reached adolescence. So the first issue was, is there any change or growth or development beyond adolescent? And then from the other end of the lifespan, there were a number of studies going on and a number of people who studied aging and old age, namely the gerontologists and the geriatur. and they were focused more on the problems of old age, like the illnesses of old age and issues
当我开始读研究生时，这种生命周期方法相对较新。事实上，我们真正被教导的是，成长和发展在青春期就基本停止了。这很大程度上源于弗洛伊德或皮亚杰等早期理论家，他们认为你的认知或心理发展在青春期结束时就完成了。所以第一个问题是，青春期之后还有任何变化、成长或发展吗？然后从生命周期的另一端来看，当时有很多研究正在进行，也有很多人研究衰老和老年，即老年学家和老年医学家，他们更多地关注老年问题，比如老年疾病和
that weren't really tied to growth and development. So the first issue that really attracted my attention was this notion that we could grow and develop in positive ways throughout adulthood. Then what we saw was most of the initial work in this area was comparing college students and older adults. There was a big gap in the middle. So we wanted to see how people age just by comparing older people with younger people. And that really led to some misleading conclusions, these cross-sectional studies comparing people from different birth cohorts who had different experiences. And we didn't really know much about what happened in the middle. We just assumed it was a straight line. Whatever happened in young adulthood was kind of on a downward trajectory
与成长和发展无关的问题。因此，真正吸引我注意的第一个问题是，我们可以在整个成年期以积极的方式成长和发展的观念。然后我们看到，该领域的大多数初步工作都是比较大学生和老年人。中间有一个巨大的空白。所以我们想通过比较老年人和年轻人来看看人们是如何衰老的。这确实导致了一些误导性的结论，这些横断面研究比较了来自不同出生队列、有不同经历的人。我们对中间发生的事情知之甚少。我们只是假设它是一条直线。年轻时发生的任何事情都处于下降轨迹，
and the middle was somewhere in between. We also really didn't think there was much going on in midlife. We thought, okay, yeah, menopause is certainly going on, hormonal changes, but we didn't think much else was going on of interest psychologically. Well, that was a misconception for sure, because we've now since then learned quite a bit. So that's really where things started, this interest in midlife. The other thing I would say is that initially it was very hard,
而中间部分则介于两者之间。我们也真的认为中年时期没什么事情发生。我们想，好吧，更年期肯定在发生，荷尔蒙在变化，但我们认为没有其他值得心理学关注的事情。嗯，那肯定是一个误解，因为从那时起我们已经学到了很多。所以这确实是事情开始的地方，对中年的兴趣。我要说的另一件事是，最初这非常困难，
to study people in midlife because we would try to bring them into our labs to test them on cognitive tests or personality. And they were very busy. They're working. They have families. They didn't have any time really to spare to come into our labs. So it got so hard to get people in middle age. I think a lot of people threw up their hands and said, let's just focus on the freshman college students in Intra Psych and the older retired people who had time and were interested in coming into the lab. Wow, that's a big gap there in the middle. Yeah. What are the characteristics, the personality traits of people who hit midlife and age well?
去研究中年人，因为我们会试图把他们带到实验室进行认知测试或人格测试。他们非常忙。他们在工作。他们有家庭。他们真的没有时间来我们的实验室。所以让中年人参与变得如此困难，我想很多人都放弃了，说让我们只关注心理学入门课上的大一新生和有时间且有兴趣来实验室的退休老人。哇，中间确实有一个巨大的空白。是的。那些步入中年并衰老得很好的人，有什么特征和人格特质？
I mean, you can see that they're going to do okay. Yeah. So we're interested in personality and also a number of other psychosocial type factors. So there's been a number of longitudinal studies that have focused on conscientiousness as a personality trait. And this is basically people who are hardworking and care about really producing good work and good outcomes. And they're very interested in doing well in all of their different endeavors. And these are the people who have the best health and they live longer. So a number of longitudinal studies have shown high conscientiousness leads to much better health outcomes and even longer life.
我的意思是，你可以看出他们会过得很好。是的。所以我们对人格以及许多其他社会心理因素感兴趣。因此，已经有许多纵向研究关注“尽责性”作为一种人格特质。这基本上是指那些努力工作、关心产生良好工作成果的人。他们非常有兴趣在所有不同的努力中表现出色。这些人拥有最好的健康状况，而且寿命更长。因此，许多纵向研究表明，高尽责性会导致更好的健康结果，甚至更长的寿命。
So that's one example. Some of the other factors that we find are purpose in life. People who basically have a sense of meaning, they know what it is that they are doing while they're getting up in the morning and feel that they have made important contributions. And this is related also to things like longevity and to lower risk of dementia. So those are some examples. Are there differences among the various generations? like have baby boomers handled midlife differently from Gen X
这是一个例子。我们发现的其他一些因素是“人生目标”。那些基本上有意义感的人，他们知道自己早上起床是为了什么，并觉得他们做出了重要的贡献。这也与长寿和降低痴呆症风险等因素有关。所以这些是一些例子。不同世代之间有差异吗？比如婴儿潮一代处理中年危机的方式与 X 世代有何不同，
and what's happening to the millennials who are the latest group of folks to hit midlife? Yeah, this is something that many people are interested in. Millions of millennials are entering midlife. The oldest millennials are in their early 40s, and they are really nervous about midlife. They are expecting a midlife crisis. And I think rightfully so,
以及对于作为最新步入中年的千禧一代来说，发生了什么？是的，这是许多人感兴趣的事情。数以百万计的千禧一代正在步入中年。最年长的千禧一代已经 40 多岁了，他们对中年感到非常紧张。他们期待着中年危机。我认为这是理所当然的，
this time and history has a lot of stress and a lot of concern and a lot of issues that are affecting people's lives. And we've looked actually in some of our studies at generational differences. We don't know much about millennials, unfortunately, because they're not in midlife yet. A very small number have just started midlife and we haven't really studied them much. But when we compare Bady boomers with Gen X or even the silent generation, the older generation, we have shown some cohort differences with Gen X showing more negative outcomes with regard to life satisfaction, higher depression, and greater loneliness. We're going to take a short break.
这个时代和历史充满了压力、担忧和许多影响人们生活的问题。我们实际上在一些研究中观察了代际差异。不幸的是，我们对千禧一代了解不多，因为他们还没有步入中年。极少数人刚刚开始中年，我们还没有真正深入研究他们。但是，当我们比较婴儿潮一代与 X 世代，甚至与沉默的一代（更年长的一代）时，我们确实发现了一些队列差异，X 世代在生活满意度方面表现出更多的负面结果，抑郁程度更高，孤独感更强。我们要休息一下。
When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Lockman about how people can navigate the work, caregiving, and other responsibilities that pile up in midlife without becoming overwhelmed. This episode is brought to you by L'Oreal Group. Beauty is a powerful force that moves us. That's why L'Oreal Group has built a business that is inclusive at its heart with 100% of its brands, championing diversity. With 25,000 professional opportunities for people under 30 worldwide and 54% of leading positions held by women, diversity is a strength that helps L'Oreal Group create the best beauty products for all people. Visit L'Oreal.com to learn more.
回来后，我将与拉赫曼博士讨论人们如何在不被压垮的情况下，处理中年时期堆积的工作、照料和其他责任。本期节目由欧莱雅集团赞助播出。美是一种推动我们的强大力量。这就是为什么欧莱雅集团建立了一个以包容为核心的企业，其 100% 的品牌都倡导多样性。在全球范围内为 30 岁以下的人群提供 25,000 个职业机会，且 54% 的领导职位由女性担任，多样性是一种力量，帮助欧莱雅集团为所有人创造最好的美容产品。访问 L'Oreal.com 了解更多信息。
One of the stressors of midlife is the fact that many people at this stage are caring for so many other people. I think we've talked about this a little bit. They're raising children. They're helping with aging parents. Maybe they're helping their neighbors or they're mentoring younger colleagues. How can people navigate this pile up of responsibilities without becoming overwhelmed? Yeah. So the roles that people have in midlife can be overwhelming for sure.
中年时期的压力源之一是许多处于这个阶段的人正在照顾许多其他人。我想我们已经讨论过这一点了。他们在抚养孩子。他们在帮助年迈的父母。也许他们在帮助邻居，或者在指导年轻的同事。人们如何在不被压垮的情况下处理这些堆积的责任？是的。人们在中年时期承担的角色确实可能让人不知所措。
Many people in midlife are caring for not only their own children, but also their elderly parents. And there's very little time for yourself. So this can be stressful. But one of the things I like to emphasize is that this caring for other people is actually good for your health. There's been a lot of research to show that those people who are engaged in interpersonal relationships, taking care of other people, interacting with other people, those people have better health and live longer. So one thing is to just think about this as a good thing in that
许多中年人不仅要照顾自己的孩子，还要照顾年迈的父母。留给自己的时间很少。所以这可能会带来压力。但我喜欢强调的一点是，这种照顾他人实际上对你的健康有益。有很多研究表明，那些参与人际关系、照顾他人、与他人互动的人，他们的健康状况更好，寿命更长。所以有一点是，把这看作是一件好事，因为
people are indeed doing something good for themselves as well as for other people. That said, it's also important to realize that you can focus more on other people and neglect yourself, and that's not good for your health. What we find is that a balance between giving support and receiving support is really what's most helpful in terms of one's own social, well-being and physical health. So that's important to keep in mind. And I also wanted to point out that this notion of caring for others is really central in midlife. And people in midlife are really cut out for this. Eric Erickson, a famous psychologist, talked about generativity as the major task of midlife. And he meant basically caring for younger generations. Certainly your own
人们确实在为自己和他人做一些有益的事情。话虽如此，也要意识到你可能会过多地关注他人而忽视自己，这对你的健康不利。我们发现，在给予支持和接受支持之间取得平衡，对于个人的社会福祉和身体健康最有帮助。所以这一点要记住。我还想指出，这种照顾他人的观念在中年时期确实是核心。中年人确实适合做这件事。著名的心理学家埃里克·埃里克森谈到了“繁衍感”是中年时期的主要任务。他的意思基本上是照顾年轻一代。当然是你的
children if you have children, but also for people in the community and people at work. So this is a central task of midlife. So if people recognize it and they realize that it is good for their own psychological and physical development, I think that helps. That said, people have to put things off sometimes because you are so engrossed in the lives of other people and do have to delay some of the things that you might want to do for yourself. But I think of that as a good thing, and I call it shelving, the shelving approach, where it's not that you're not going to be able to do it, not be able to go back to school
孩子（如果你有孩子的话），还有社区里的人和工作中的人。所以这是中年的核心任务。因此，如果人们认识到这一点，并意识到这对他们自己的心理和身体发展有益，我认为这会有所帮助。话虽如此，人们有时必须推迟一些事情，因为你太沉浸在别人的生活中，确实必须推迟一些你可能想为自己做的事情。但我认为这是一件好事，我称之为“搁置”，即搁置方法，并不是说你以后做不到，不能回去上学
or and earn the degree that you want or take the courses that you want or go on the trip that you want. You have to shelve it. That is put it on hold for later. And that really is liberating in a way because what you're thinking is it's not that I can't do it. I just can't do it now. And it's something that you can look forward to when you do have. You do more time and you're less focused on the lives of other people. Are there other things that people should be thinking about in their 40s and 50s to set themselves up for healthy aging? I know you've done a lot of research in this area. Yes. So one of the things that's really important to acknowledge is that once health in midlife
或者获得你想要的学位，或者参加你想要的课程，或者去你想要的旅行。你必须搁置它。也就是说，把它暂时搁置起来。这在某种程度上是解放性的，因为你的想法是：不是我做不到，只是我现在做不到。当你拥有更多时间，并且不再那么专注于别人的生活时，这是你可以期待的事情。在 40 多岁和 50 多岁时，人们还应该考虑哪些事情来为健康衰老做好准备？我知道你在这一领域做了很多研究。是的。所以有一点非常重要，那就是中年时期的健康
does have a long reach into later life, so things like your blood pressure in midlife is very important for cardiovascular brain health in later life. Some studies show even more important than the blood pressure in later life. That doesn't mean you shouldn't have good blood pressure in later life, but it's just the blood pressure in midlife sets the stage for how things go much later. Other things, such as physical fitness, your weight, your sleep habits in midlife, they all are predictive of health outcomes in later years. So therefore, in midlife, it really is important to nip health problems in the bud and help avoid problems later on. The one thing I call a panacea is physical activity.
确实对晚年有深远的影响，所以像中年时期的血压对晚年的心血管和大脑健康非常重要。一些研究表明，这甚至比晚年的血压更重要。这并不意味着你在晚年不应该有良好的血压，只是中年时期的血压为以后的情况奠定了基础。其他事情，如身体素质、体重、中年时期的睡眠习惯，都预示着晚年的健康结果。因此，在中年时期，确实有必要将健康问题扼杀在萌芽状态，并帮助避免以后的问题。我称之为“万灵药”的一件事是体育锻炼。
And I call it that because every study shows the positive benefits of physical activity. Whether it's walking or other forms of activity, it really does pay off in terms of your physical, cognitive psychological health. and people who engage in regular physical activity have a reduced risk of cardiovascular disease, cancer, frailty, dementia, depression, and they live longer. So I don't know of really many other things out there that can claim to have such widespread long-term effects. And I do recommend engaging in regular physical activity starting in midlife if you haven't already started that. Yeah. You've been looking at this question for a long time. I'm wondering, do you still get surprised by anything as you're doing your research? Yes, I do. So the thing that surprises me the most is how important your attitudes and beliefs and mindset are. As a psychologist, I wanted to believe that because that's what I'm interested in. I'm most interested in how people think about their lives, the attitudes that they have, the beliefs that they have about their sense.
我之所以这样称呼它，是因为每一项研究都显示了体育锻炼的积极益处。无论是步行还是其他形式的活动，它在身体、认知和心理健康方面确实都有回报。参与定期体育锻炼的人患心血管疾病、癌症、虚弱、痴呆症、抑郁症的风险降低，而且寿命更长。所以我不知道还有什么其他东西能声称具有如此广泛的长期影响。如果你还没有开始，我确实建议从中年开始进行定期的体育锻炼。是的。你研究这个问题已经很长时间了。我想知道，你在做研究时还会对任何事情感到惊讶吗？是的，我会。所以最让我惊讶的是你的态度、信念和心态有多重要。作为一名心理学家，我想相信这一点，因为这就是我感兴趣的。我最感兴趣的是人们如何思考他们的生活，他们持有的态度，他们对自己的控制感、人生目标、乐观精神的信念。所以我们着手研究这些社会心理因素，看看它们在多大程度上确实与你的结果相关。我们发现它们确实相关。它们确实对你的健康和福祉有很大影响。所以这让我感到惊讶，但这确实是我希望发现的事情。我们正在很大程度上关注这一点，因为这些是你可以真正改变的信念和态度。
of control, their purpose in life, their optimism. So we set out to look at these psychosocial factors to see to what extent they are, in fact, related to your outcome. And we found they are. They really do have a big effect on your health and well-being. And so that, it surprised me, but it was really something I was hoping to find. And we are focusing on that to a large extent, because these are, believe, and attitudes that you can actually change.
所以我们所做的大部分工作实际上是在寻找可改变的因素，我们可以解决的可改变因素，这些因素可以对健康产生长期益处。这项研究如何影响了你自己的生活方式以及你处理中年时期的方式？啊，思考这个问题很有趣。是的，我认为它对我产生了影响，可能最明显的是，因为我非常清楚随着年龄增长而来的所有变化，我知道衰老会带来什么。所以我认为我没有像许多其他人那样对衰老过程感到那么紧张、不安或担忧，
And so most of what we do is really looking for factors that are modifiable, modifiable factors that we can address that can have long-term benefits for help. How has this research affected the way you live your own life and the way you approached your midlife? Ah, that's interesting to think about that. Yeah, I think it has had an effect on me, probably the most, obvious is that because I was very aware of all the changes that come with age, I knew what to expect with aging. And so I don't think I got as nervous or upset or worried about aging,
那些人可能对他们正在经历的事情感到更加惊讶。我也意识到了生命中可能出现的各种积极变化，而不是专注于消极方面。所以我尽量专注于我们将会经历的收获，而不是我们都会经历的损失。所以我非常清楚我所说的风险因素和保护因素，并尽量将它们融入到我的生活中。你还希望人们从书中或更广泛的研究中获得哪些其他重要的教训？所以我想说，选择积极的心态很重要。有很多来自其他人以及我们自己的研究表明，对衰老的消极态度确实是有害的，对你执行日常任务能力的消极态度，认为与衰老相关的所有变化都是走下坡路，而不是专注于所有的积极事物，比如自信心的增强、自尊心的增强，这些事情确实值得关注。
the aging process, as many other people who may have been more surprised by the things that they were experiencing. And so I also realized all the positive changes that could come throughout life rather than focusing on the negative. So I tried to focus more on the gains that we would experience rather than the losses that we all do experience as well. So I was very well aware of what I call risk factors and protective factors, and I tried to incorporate them into my life as best as I could. Any other important lessons that you want people to take away from the book
所以现在，许多人感到压力，因为世界可能感觉完全失控了。经济、气候和其他方面发生了很多事情。所以很难采取积极的态度。但是积极的态度，如乐观、控制感、了解自己的人生目标，都与更好的健康和长寿有关。所以我认为人们采取积极的心态很重要。我还想补充一点，特别是在中年方面，我书的标题是《黄金时间》。
or from your research more broadly? So I would say it's important to choose a positive mindset. There's a lot of research out there by others and our work as well that show that negative attitudes about aging are really harmful and negative attitudes about your ability to carry out your everyday tasks, thinking that all the changes that are associated with aging, it's all downhill rather than focusing on all the, the positive things like gains in confidence, gains in self-esteem, those things are really important to focus on.
我选择这个标题是因为我认为这是一个重要的重构，人们应该拥抱它，因为我们被兜售了一种关于中年的消极图景，一种衰退的叙事，终结的开始。但我们的研究确实显示了一些非常不同的东西。中年是一个非常重要的时期。你拥有丰富的经验，对什么重要的事情有更清晰的认识，并且拥有几十年来磨练出的许多技能。而且还有很多时间。所以我认为以这种心态对待中年很重要。
So right now, many people feel stressed because the world may feel like it's totally out of control. There's so many things going on with the economy and climate and other things. And so it's hard to adopt a positive attitude. But positive attitudes such as optimism, a sense of control, knowing your purpose in life, they're all related to better health and longevity. So I think it's important that people adopt a positive mindset. I might add also specifically with regard to midlife, the title of my book is prime time.
然后它确实可以被视为一个充实的时期，一个充满成长、享受和机会的时期。那么，总结一下，你接下来要做什么？我的意思是，我知道你刚完成一本书，你可能（你知道）松了一口气。但考虑到这一点，你还没有完成你的研究，对吧？所以你还在看什么？是的。所以我们现在关注的是真正继续了解从中年开始健康衰老的风险和保护因素，因为我们确实想采取预防方法。我们可以在中年时期做些什么，不仅是为了丰富中年时期，而且是为了优化健康衰老？我们正在研究的一件事是我所说的“健康衰老的社会心理处方”。这确实与社会心理因素有关。
And I picked that because I think it's an important reframe for people to embrace because we have been sold a negative picture of midlife, a narrative of decline, the beginning of the end. but our research really shows something very different. This is a really important time in midlife. You have a lot of experience and more clarity about what matters and many skills that you've honed over the decades. And there's also a lot of time. So I think it's important to approach midlife with this mindset.
我之前提到了一些，比如拥有人生目标、控制感，即你觉得即使有很多限制和障碍，你也可以做一些事情来实现你的目标和结果。还有社会支持。这些是我们发现确实与中年及以后的健康和福祉相关的因素。我们对为什么这些因素相关很感兴趣。机制是什么？
And then it really can be seen as a fulfilling time, with a period of growth, enjoyment, and opportunity. So to wrap up, what's next for you? I mean, I know you just finished a book and you're probably, you know, relieved. But given that, you're not done doing your research, right? So what else are you looking at? Yes. So what we're focusing on now is really continuing to understand what are the risk and protective factors for healthy aging starting in midlife because we really want to take a prevention approach. What can we do in midlife to not only enrich the midlife period, but to optimize healthy aging? And one of the things that we're working on is what I call a psychosocial prescription for healthy aging. And this is really related to the psychosocial factors.
它们是如何相关的？所以我们当然在关注行为因素，比如人们通常会考虑不吸烟、低度或适度饮酒、体育锻炼。但我们也确实在关注其他因素，如炎症、压力荷尔蒙。压力是一个非常重要的因素，我们已经开始关注它。所以也许这些社会心理因素可以减轻压力。有一些证据支持这一点。如果你有社会支持或控制感，你就不太可能感到压力。我们知道压力会致命。我们知道压力对健康非常有破坏性。所以我们真的在努力
I mentioned some of them earlier, such as having a purpose in life, a sense of control, where you feel that there are things you can do to reach to your goals and outcomes, even though there are many constraints and obstacles. But also social support. Those are things that we find are indeed related to health and well-being in midlife and beyond in later life as well. And we're interested in why these factors are related. What are the mechanisms?
理解这个社会心理处方，它是如何工作的。有哪些因素？炎症被证明是一个非常重要的机制。慢性炎症，我们在我们的 MIDUS 研究中测量过，我们可以看到那些有更高控制感的人确实有更低水平的炎症。那些有更高社会支持的人有更低水平的炎症。我们知道炎症，有时被称为“炎症衰老”，因为炎症实际上与晚年的许多疾病结果有关，例如癌症、心血管疾病和痴呆症。
How are they related? So we're focusing on behavioral factors, of course, things like people typically will think about not smoking and low or moderate drinking, physical activity. But we're also really looking at other factors such as inflammation, stress hormones. Stress is a very important factor. that we have started to look at. So maybe these psychosocial factors reduce stress. There's some evidence for that. If you have social support or sense of control, you're less likely to be stressed. And we know stress can kill. We know stress is very damaging for health. So we're really trying to
好吧，拉赫曼博士，我想感谢您今天参加我的节目。我认为您给了我们的听众很多重要、有用的建议。非常感谢。我很喜欢和你交谈。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的节目有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们：
understand this psychosocial prescription, how it works. What are the factors? And inflammation turns out to be a very important mechanism. Chronic inflammation, which we, We measure in our mites study, we can see that those who have a higher sense of control do have lower levels of inflammation. Those who have higher social support have lower levels of inflammation. And we know that inflammation, it's sometimes called inflamaging because inflammation is, in fact, tied to so many outcomes of disease in later life, cancer, cardiovascular disease, and dementia, for example.
Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。感谢收听，我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Well, Dr. Lachman, I want to thank you for joining me today. I think you've given our listeners a lot of important, helpful tips. Thank you very much. I enjoy talking with you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at
好的，拉赫曼博士，非常感谢您今天能来参加节目。我认为您为我们的听众提供了许多重要且有益的建议。非常感谢您，我很享受与您的交谈。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何您收听播客的平台上找到《心理学谈话》往期的节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请订阅并留下评论。如果您对未来的节目有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至
Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·怀纳曼制作。感谢您收听美国心理学会的节目，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。